my pleasure thanks for having me
I want to start by asking you about your
background and whether it was a
classical background in terms of music
or whether it was something else
entirely
well no I mean I come from you know the
the good old traditional lying around in
bed being on the dole trying to form the
rock-and-roll band you know I had a mmm
uh sort of schooling in church music I
played the organ when I left school I
went and played in bands and then did
some session work on the guitar I also
then studied music again and so I had
this kind of strange mix of sort of semi
formal than nothing for more and then
more formal sort of like that I started
playing the piano because I was very
jealous of my brother and he wanted
piano lessons so I won't be other
lessons too I just found I completely
loved it straight away it was just
something that I wanted to play I wanted
to compose I started with piano when I
was a kid about six and I also started
singing the Boys Choir and I sang for
about ten years my parents are a great
music lovers they took me to concerts
they took me to operas and we were
listening to music a lot at home and so
that was the that was the beginning I
was in I was in populate itself like 10
years after a while it sort of dawned on
me that you know first course of this
course wasn't really doing it for me you
know what's the point of a second verse
if it's just the same as I mean in the
Ramones brilliant you know third verse
same as the first fantastic but once
you've kind of made that statement
it's almost redundant but you know when
I started to work because I did all
kinds of things like row
being four people and doing takedowns
for bands and things like that you know
I but when I started to work like
playing more I mean literally in London
then there were probably 25 or 30
studios that would be working more or
less round-the-clock so there was a lot
of people writing stuff out you know and
even though there were synthesizers but
there wasn't programming and sequencing
and all of that like there is now for a
while I worked in the shop as in a music
shop as a shop assistant and I was kind
of doing some technical support and
music software and then because I knew
some music software I was able to become
freelance and help other composers
I've always loved film and I love film
music but I kind of always thought that
it was a job other people did you know
you think how the hell you get into that
you know I'm not still thinking that the
son degree I think the interesting thing
about being a musician and composer in
the games industry is that everybody has
come from such different roots because
when we started making games they
weren't any games courses he couldn't
come through a traditional route so I
think the nice thing is actually in the
indie scene you can be from a band or
you can be classically trained it's so
diverse so it's quite an unusual
certainly a more modern roots getting
into film composers yeah would you have
any particular bits of advice to give to
people who are starting out now that
there are many different rote element
and I guess every composer story is
slightly different I mean it probably
does come down to getting a break at
some point but you know I mean a lot of
people a lot of the guys are you know
are classically trained and
compositionally trained and now which
I'm not you know I have never been
taught the conventions of film
composition if you're like it's probably
easier now to produce your music because
there are some fantastic computer
programs and sampled and and softer and
the problem is that because it's easier
to realize them there are also more
people than that do it I think the key
is just get to know people and make
those connections build your networks I
think that's the key and someone will
like your music my music has been
unfashionable for so many years and my
mom gave me such good advice and said if
you're chasing fashion you're always
going to be behind it stay true to what
you do be passionate about it and
somebody will provide that good fit for
you and I think it's about being
proactive about finding that good food
the best thing that could happen to a
young composer of starting is to be able
to collaborate with young director Rizal
to starting or young producers also
starting and kind of try to grow
together and I think that if you develop
relationships in that way which you can
quite easily in in theatre or in short
films or you know these things I mean
these things aren't going to make you
rich but they can lead on to other
things my only thing would be whatever
route you take I think it's important to
be yourself and find find whatever it is
in you that you that you want to express
you know and I spent our ages like
thinking what does my stuff sound as
goes at Chemical Brothers why does it
sound as good as Daft Punk or whatever
you know but you know the reality of
that was like those guys are brilliant
what they do and I'm not those guys and
I don't know and it took me a while to
sort of go you know what just do what
you do do your thing because there
aren't really any right or wrong answers
in music
I think you can basically do what you
want and to develop your own voice you
know is in the end what matters so
however it's best to do that
you know if it's whether if it's best to
do that in a safe environment being
apprenticed to somebody who you admire
and you can understand what they do and
then you can go your own way slightly
that's one way or the other way is to
slug it out you know in the province is
somewhere in doing a bit of this for a
theatre and a bit of sound design and
things like that and I thought I think
either ways good